formation géographiques et sociales le
marché en support à cet exposé le
syllabus de géographie notions
théoriques les pages 153 à 156 la
préparation qui est liée à cet exposé
vidéo sera un questionnaire qui vous
sera proposé
juste en dessous de la vidéo sur ben
loger le marché qu'est ce que le marché
le marché c'est un lieu de rencontre qui
peut être fictif entre l'ensemble des
offres émanant des producteurs et
l'ensemble de la vente qui provient des
consommateurs ou des entreprises
les échanges se font grâce à la monnaie
qui est en fait l'argent qui permet de
fixer un prix pour les biens et les
services échangés entre les producteurs
c'est-à-dire les entreprises et les
consommateurs qui peuvent être des
ménages ou des entreprises
adam smith est le premier à définir le
mécanisme des prix comme une main
invisible qui permettrait de réguler
l'économie
il entendait par là invisible la
non-intervention le mécanisme des prix
par lui-même par son seul fonctionnement
va réguler l'ensemble des échanges sur
le marché
vous voyez sur le graphique de droite
deux axes où je retrouve les prix des
produits et la quantité de produits
échangés sur un marché vous trouvez deux
courbes la courbe de demandes en rouge
et la courbe d'or en bleu pour chaque
prix il y à une hausse qui correspond à
une quantité pour chaque prix il demande
qui correspond à une candide
l'idée est que plus les prix augmentent
plus je suis homo sur cet axe - la
demande est importante - la quantité est
importante voyez ici pour un prix très
élevé j'ai une toute petite quantité
par contre du côté des producteurs plus
le prix élevé
est élevé plus les producteurs accepte
de produire évidemment le bénéfice sera
plus important ce qui fait qu'à un
certain moment on va avoir les deux
coupes qui vont se rencontrer à un prix
d'équilibré à cet endroit si précisément
il y à un prix qui convient à la fois à
la demande et à l'offre
on obtient un prix et une quantité d
équilibre chacun est d'accord de payer
le bon prix maintenant imaginons une
augmentation de la demande
il n'y aura dans tous les cas plus de
quantités demandées vous voyez que ma
courbe à chaque fois va correspondre
pour un prix à une quantité supérieure
de ce qui était échangé précédemment
puisque ici la quantité présidente était
situé ici maintenant je suis ici
s'il ya augmentation de la demande
je vais avoir constitution d'un nouvel
équilibre le prix va augmenter ainsi que
la quantité
par contre si j'ai une réduction de la
demande
les quantités vont diminuer et le prix
du produit sur le marché va diminuer de
la même façon une réduction de l'offre
des producteurs décident de ne plus
produire le produit va créer un nouvel
équilibre ici par rapport à la demande
qui est resté stable
les quantités échangées seront moindres
mais le prix sera supérieur enfin
dernier cas de figure si l'offre aux
demandes cette fois ci il y à de
nouveaux acteurs du nouveau producteur
sur le marché
les quantités disponibles sont plus
importantes mais par le mécanisme des
prix on aura une diminution de celui ci
il ya trois grands marchés le marché des
biens et des services
le marché du travail et les marchés
financiers le marché de biens et
services est le plus évident nous ne
l'aborderons non pas dans cette vidéo le
marché du travail comme
quant à lui à la rencontre entre une
demande de travail qui émane des
employeurs les employeurs veulent une
force de travail s'il vous voulez une
quantité de travail et une offre
d'oeuvres de travail qui est proposée
par les travailleurs à ne pas confondre
bien sûr avec une offre et une demande
d'emploi qui est l' inverse
la demande d'emploi émane du travailleur
tandis que l'offre d'emploi émane de
l'employeur sur le graphique de droit
vous voyez que contrairement au marché
des biens et des services
le prix est remplacé par le salaire
les quantités sont toujours des
quantités en termes de quantité de
travail
je vais aussi avoir une constitution
d'un prix demandés d'un salaire
équilibre et d'une cantine de travail d'
équilibre ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous voyez que dans certaines
situations
si le salaire est fixé comme ici le cas
français le smic
si on a un salaire fixe et un certain
moment ça peut créer un décalage entre
l'offre et la demande l'offre est
supérieure à la demande
et j'ai donc ici la raison du chômage
a contrario une demande plus importante
que l'offre va créer une pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et donc une augmentation
des salaires à l' équilibre
le salaire réel est égale à la
productivité marginale du travail mais
ceci n'est pas pouvoir le cours de jura
le marché financier reprend content lui
a quant à lui les change des devises
c'est à dire des monnaies locales ou
étrangères reprend les échanges de
capitaux
c'est à dire d'argent l'investissement
et les produits financiers qui peuvent
exister obligations actions sur le
marché financier
on ne parle pas de prix mais le taux
d'intérêt le taux d'intérêt exprimées en
pourcentage est un petit peu le prix que
vous payez pour emprunter ou pour prêter
de l'argent
un taux de 2% veut dire que à chaque
échéance
vous devez rendre ou recevoir 2 % de la
valeur prêter ou
cet exposé est maintenant finie la
préparation est expliqué en début de
vidéo et je vous souhaite un bon travail
et un bon week-end